I'm Jesse
people innovators what's up ritual here
wanna be for haters curious plan here's
what kind of crazy nonsense to do
welcome to our holiday recipe cookie so
today we're gonna do the mix green
holiday pilaf and right now I'm gonna
slice this red chard and kind of thick
strips right out all the way down to the
stalk compost that is this Tyler I
always want to eat one of the
complicated more complicated recipes in
the car just make it for you actually
it's actually not sweet actually
it's really easy but it's holiday it was
the recipe we had that said holiday mix
peel off so how could I not include in
our demo so any way or any holiday so
we're just gonna get that
been chopped red chard richhart is a
dark leafy green it's on the bitter side
kind of like kale
it stops cooking we have brown basmati
rice very basic it cooks up really
quickly it should take about 15 or 20
minutes
so I'm gonna put a cup of bath and I've
got a cup of red quinoa put in there so
now we're gonna do four tablespoons
olive oil and this is approximately so
you may like a little less you may like
a little more another question yeah this
what kind of taste good it's gonna taste
great it tastes like it tastes like
it's like a mixed grant was gonna scare
your extended family members no it
tastes great it's just a mixed drink
it's lovely and the apple cider vinegar
really works well with the bitter taste
of the chard we're gonna take just a
pitch of this beautiful Celtic sea salt
okay so we're just gonna go like that
we're gonna add in 1/2 a cup of organic
dried cranberries and then I'm going to
go over to the oven see you simply take
raw pumpkin seeds put them flat flat on
a cookie sheet bake them at about 350 or
400 for about 5 minutes and they're
ready to go so I'm gonna put about about
1/2 a cup in there ok so just mix it all
together toss it and you've got mixed
grain pilaf with red chard and pumpkin
seeds